actually  putin wants to destroy ukraine and wants  to kill all ukrainians we see it in  his speeches  we see in  it in the speeches of his authorities  but when i as a prosecutor should go to  the court i should come with evidences i  will give you evidences when i will have  access to this territory i think that it  is strategy of the  chief of commander  because we see the same strategy in  other countries actually when they come  to cities and when cities don't want to  capitulate um they have plan a  cities should capitulate if cities are  not capital uh uh wasn't capillary  related it means  that plan b  to scare this population for maximum  kill  rape or  torture and other and other brutal  things it is strategic law